do you think the entire thing could be
learning because they're uh this
dissection process like for ai feynman
the secondary stage feels like something
like
reasoning and the initial step feels
like more like the
the more basic kind of differentiable
learning
do you think the whole thing could be
differentiable learning
basically neural networks on top of each
other it's like turtles all the way down
can you be neural networks all the way
down i mean it's that's a really
interesting question we know that in
in your case it is neural networks all
the way down because that's
all you have in your skull there's a
bunch of neurons doing their thing right
yeah but if you ask the question
more generally what what algorithms are
your brain is your brain
are being used in your brain right i
think it's super interesting to compare
i think we've gone a little bit
backwards historically because
we humans first discovered good
old-fashioned ai the logic based ai that
we often called
gofi for good old-fashioned ai
and then more recently we did machine
learning
because it required bigger computers so
we had to discover it later
so we think of machine learning with
neural networks
as the modern thing and the logic based
ai as the old-fashioned thing
but if you look at evolution on earth
right it's actually been the other way
around
i would i would say that for example
an eagle has a better vision system
than i have using and
dogs are just as good at casting tennis
balls as i am
all this stuff which is done by training
a neural network
and not interpreting it in words you
know
is something so many of our animal
friends can do at least as well as us
right
what is it that we humans can do that
the chipmunks and the eagles cannot
it's more to do with this logic based
stuff right where we can
extract out information in symbols
in language and now even with equations
if you're a scientist
right so basically what happened was
first we built these computers that
could
multiply numbers real fast and
manipulate symbols and we felt they were
pretty dumb
and that and then we made neural
networks that can see as well as a cat
can
and do a lot of this inscrutable black
box
neural networks what we humans can do
also is put the two together in a useful
way
yes artificially in our own brain yes in
our own brain so
if we ever want to get artificial
general intelligence that can do all
jobs as well as humans can right then
that's what's going to be required
to be able to combine the neural
networks with with um
symbolic combine the old ai with a new
ai in a good way
you